ein virus aus china geht um die welt
tourt und eine millionen menschen und
auf dem höhepunkt des us wahlkampfs wird
auf einmal der us-präsident selber
gefallen und ist nun im krankenhaus im
walter reed dorthin geflogen worden vom
weißen haus das ist tatsächlich alles
etwas was man vermutlich bei house of
cards wenn man es da gesehen hätte er
nicht geglaubt hätte wie haben sie die
letzten tage wahrgenommen und vor allem
was glauben sie wie das jetzt den
wahlkampf von donald trump oder die
us-wahl insgesamt verändern wird also
wahrscheinlich wäre ein solches drehbuch
in hollywood wurden fraktion zunächst
wir präsident trump seiner frau und den
mitarbeitern die infiziert sind alles
gute dass er so schnell wie möglich
wieder gesund wird dann auch so schnell
wie möglich wieder ins weiße haus
zurückkehren kann
wie sich das auswirken wird auf die
präsidentschaftswahlen das kann ich
wirklich nicht beurteilen das müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger in den
vereinigten staaten tun
ich hoffe dass der fokus nicht zu sehr
abgelenkt von dem um was es geht nämlich
wer hat welche vorstellungen zudem dazu
der zukunft der vereinigten staaten
aber ich glaube dass man zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt das gar nicht
sagen kann was ich glaube ehrlich sind
auch diejenigen die behaupten das ist
wissen wie sie es ausdrücken wird die
wissen s wirklich auch nicht also das
wird möglicherweise durchaus noch mal
einiges durcheinander würde aber wie das
sein wird kann glaube ich keiner
beurteilen deshalb wäre es gut wenn der
präsident so schnell wie möglich wieder
gesund wird auch zurückkehren kann in
den wahlkampf dass es auch noch mal
mindestens ein duell gibt mit seinem
herausforderer beiden damit sich die
wählerin wähler im bild machen können
wie sie sich dann anfang november
entscheiden